[Musique]
jamais faire prétentieux si je dicte une
bombe sexuelle non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mecs qui parlent que de leur quête
ils sont persuadés qu' il faut en avoir
une grande une grosse et que leur nous
on est vachement contente et tout alors
que c'est pas du tout ça c'est un
travailleur de la quête je suis parti en
élite
à dix c'était bien alors pouette pouette
pour être gentil alors étudiant en vrai
c'était vachement bien pilotes on se dit
bon mais il a rien compris quoi
peut-être que le porno c'était mon
service militaire c'est les situations
violentes difficile où son image
personnelle est complètement écrabouillé
réduite à néant on est vraiment d'un
paquet de viande
y'a que ça quoi c'est que l'orgasme nous
regardent avec des espèces de mécanique
qui se secouer qui se tendent vers un
orgasme chement simple comme ça
vous parlez avec les gens avec qui vous
avez une relation sexuelle peut agir
puisque par l'équipe
ça commence par des motos et doux et
parfois ça se finit carrément par des
grossièretés
j'aime beaucoup les photos des moments
où c'est les aventures comme ça d'un
soir on cherche pas vraiment du
romantisme
ça c'est quelque chose de sexuel
vachement funds à une affaire quoi j'ai
pas envie qu'on prenne sans plaisir sur
mon dos parce que c'est les hommes
rapides
ben c'est pas ça m'intéresse pas c'est
une question de y ait les yeux il ya des
femmes du red rat dans les yeux qui ont
des draps
bonjour je me considère pas une femme
qui a tout les mecs à ses pieds et puis
ça ne m'intéresse même pas je vais dire
ça sert un coin alors michel blanc est
ce qu'on peut dire de voeux vous êtes
une bombe sexuelle
maintenant on peut se poser la question
[Musique]